j'aurais pu être plombier a game enyeama
sujet est grave mais je choisis les
facteurs voilà mais qu'est ce que je
chante moi mais je ne suis plus acteur
puisque j'ai donné ma démission hier
alors françois qui a t'il julich quelle
élégance bonjour bonjour factor allons
monsieur campagne ah oui c'est vrai
bonjour monsieur campagne ça fait tout
de même drôle de vous appeler comme ça
mais vous ne regrettez rien aux absolue
pour la première fois depuis quinze
jours j'ai dormi gala sans faire le
cauchemar habituel et des montagnes de
l'être
voyez vous une nouvelle vie commence
pour moi off mes ennemis ils verront que
faites vous dans cette tenue allez vite
vous habiller un facteur et appartements
pour le nom casimir tu m'as bien entendu
donné ma démission et la wii c'était
drôle hein vraiment très drôle une bonne
blague on a bien ri et c'était de bons
acteurs et renvoyer peut-être revenir
sur votre décision ça ferait plaisir à
votre chef reçoit alors un est à nous ça
se met moins égale non
après tout facteur vous êtes assez grand
garçon pour savoir ce que vous avez à
faire respecte qui nous distrait bord à
notre courrier maintenant ben oui alors
ça c'est un problème on va retrouverons
toujours un autre os zigotos
au regard des îles retrouver lorsque
tour la poste vous salue
vos reer à mon égard sur lamy je tends
mon père siffle l'essai jusqu'à ce que
steam ou va t on j'aurais préféré chara
mais qui maillent comme un casting on
met les choses au sérieux c'est vous le
nouveau facteur non non non chars amx
seulement pour quelques jours en
attendant qu'un vrai facteur arrive oui
moi je n'ai pas voulu qu'un service
reste inactive pendant quelques jours
mais mais mais qui vont-ils nous envoyer
alors là vous factor vous n'étiez pas
super extra mais on s'était habitué à
vous et on vous aimez bien ne mendie pas
plus casimir tu vas me donné tes romans
monsieur geste noble week end venez un
petit peu par ici j'ai avouera relais et
je vais vous parler vous verrez bien
aborder de mister
suisse nomes 10 en or et les postes et
télécommunications m quoi mais bon oui
parfaitement regardez vous dans une
glace mme caya l'élu regardez-vous
mafalda parfois même si vous avez l'air
d'un clown bombe à donner votre enfance
team va parfois qu'ils n'ont pas la même
silhouette tous les noms et la casquette
est ce que c'est une des raisons pour la
pole à la porte et sont vos yeux quand
ça elle est trop grande pour moi
et la sacoche ça ne se portent pas comme
ça la sacoche d'abord du côté gauche et
alors vous la tenez avec la main gauche
l'ouvrier qu'alors vous puisez avec la
main droite les lettres arts a
apparemment de l'aisne mes chers amis
voilà alors il y à une lettre pour vous
c'est parce que voilà une aide pour vous
et net pour vous payer et tout le reste
est pour moi non casimir tu n'as que
trois lettres nord-est pour emile quand
ryan sweeting
[Musique]
bouchard était endormie comme ça
elles sont pour vous aimez
les noms mais il y en a trop et des mois
ne démissionnait pas romney c'est signé
pierre raison des facteurs facteurs
signées larry l'homme paddy nos enfants
sans facteur signé agnès et tous disent
la même chose à
1,6 l émotion excusez-moi heure aimer
les sept démissions vous la mettre n'est
toujours en plus courant alors je vais
dire avant chez qu'il me faut trois fois
plus de temps pour faire ma tournée
je suis sûr qu'il acceptera vos
conditions bon eh bien maintenant que
nous avons retrouvé notre secteur vous
pouvez continuer à écrire
[Musique]